wenn alles glatt läuft wird das
gigantische
spacex starship schon nächsten monat zu
seinem ersten flug starten das sind die
news eine absolut gigantischen
präsentation ele mast vor dem start mit
dem superhit booster die größte rakete
und das schwerste fliegende objekte
aller zeiten sie hat den doppelten schub
der bisher größten rakete der apollo
rakete saturn 5 alle infos zum science
in future hier gibt es drei mal pro
woche faszinierendes science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
auch wieder mal ein episches bild im
vordergrund steht ihre mast vor seinem
werk ohne ihn gäbe es sie nicht die
größte rakete der welt das starship mit
dem superheavy booster diese kombination
stellt alles bisher dagewesene in den
schatten und mass präsentierte noch mehr
absolut mind blowing kleiner für
starship denn das macht neben der größe
diese gigantische rakete absolut
konkurrenzlos sie ist komplett komplett
wiederverwendbare und die pläne für die
nahe sehr nahe zukunft fassade gibt es
jetzt hier vom airbag dix haus im schluh
spacex ist auf einem absoluten
erfolgstrip es hat laut imas den
heiligen gral der raketentechnik
gefunden die schnelle
wiederverwendbarkeit der raketen alleine
50 starts von ferkeln und vw wird es
dieses jahr geben es gibt bereits
booster die mehr als zehn mal gestartet
sind und jetzt ist es soweit denn mit
starship steht eine revolution an denn
nicht nur dass die gesamte rakete wieder
verwendet werden kann das schiff kann
wieder auf der erde landen im gegensatz
zu drängen oder zu decken muss das
raumschiff nicht aufwändig nach einem
wasser geborgen werden dieses jahr wird
starship aller voraussicht nach zum
ersten mal in dem erdorbit fliegen und
wenn es richtig gut läuft dann im
nächsten monat in vier bis sechs wochen
denn so maske ist es möglich dass die
bundesluftfahrtbehörde der usa dann
schon grünes licht gibt und auch mit
diesem zeitpunkt könnte man startbereit
sein also technisch dennoch gibt es
einige herausforderungen und einen der
größten ist die entwicklung des raptor
triebwerkes es ist eine fortentwicklung
des raptor one triebwerkes das wie musk
sich ausdrückte er einem weihnachtsbaum
spaghetti haufen endet web tattoo sei
deutlich vereinfacht worden und hier
sieht man deutlich wie effektiv der
elenas kurs zur forschung und
entwicklung ist sein credo mache
anforderungen weniger dumm verzichte auf
einen teil oder einem prozessschritt
vereinfacher und optimiere mache die
fertigung schneller automatisieren und
die auswirkungen der ersten drei
schritte sieht man bei raptor tun
absolut beeindruckend deutlich der
weihnachtsbaum spaghetti haufen ist weg
wobei regel eins und zwei deutlicher
beim superheavy booster zu sehen sind
perfekten ein sind die gitter flossen
beim start noch an geklappt beim
superheavy booster wurde diese mechanik
weggelassen weil sie gar nicht gebraucht
wird sie ist einfach unnötig und genau
so ist auch der weihnachtsbaum spaghetti
haufen bei wrapped up to verschwunden
allerdings gab es in den letzten wochen
äußerungen von must die auf große
probleme bei der entwicklung von reaktor
2 zu schließen hatten lassen und die und
das autonome fahren bei test sind
momentan seine größten baustellen
priorität hat aber wohl raptor tun
momentan beim us denn er hat seinen
hauptwohnsitz hier zur star basin boca
chica verlegt allerdings gibt es laut
maaß nur noch ein problem bei raptor tut
die brennkammer habe während der
gesamten renndauer das dringende
bedürfnis zu schmelzen hier sei man noch
dabei die verschiedenen kühlverfahren
auszutarieren so dass das nicht
geschehen würde ansonsten ist wohl alles
ready auch den komplizierten hitzeschutz
für den wiedereintritt von starship die
hitzekacheln könne man inzwischen robust
zuverlässig und vor allem preiswert
fertigen dank max entwicklungs
algorithmus das starship hat den großen
vorteil dass es zylindrisch ist und die
kacheln fast alle dieselbe form haben
können was wahnsinnig wichtig für die
serienproduktion und damit
kosteneinsparungen ist die vielen
verschiedenen karanam spaceshuttle waren
wegen ihrer unterschiedlichen form eine
riesige herausforderung zudem werden sie
nicht an raumschiff geklebt also wie
beim space shuttle wo sie dann ja
abfallen können was ursächlich für die
columbia -katastrophe 2003 war die
raumfähre verglühte beim wiedereintritt
weil sich an der linken flügel
vorderkante ein hitzeschild gelockert
hatte deswegen werden hitze karin bandt
starship auf metallstifte gesteckt das
problem sind allerdings die speziellen
landeklappen und deren scharniere am
starship die sogenannten lorenz nach in
massen anziehen müssen speziell
abgedichtet werden allerdings wird das
durch die stahlkonstruktion erleichtert
denn stahl schmilzt bei deutlich höheren
temperaturen als die aluminiumhülle des
space shuttles eine der hauptfragen beim
ersten flug wird also sein wird starship
den wiedereintritt unbeschädigt
überstehen und wird der superheavy
booster exakt landen denn das ist die
nächste große frage wird der launch und
catch and our der staat und fangt
umfunktionieren schon jetzt haben die
greifarme den superheavy booster und
starship auf position bringen kann aber
wird das auch beim einfangen des
boosters klappen der booster soll
nämlich direkt neben dem tower und
optimal direkt in den greifarmen lampen
und es gibt wieder planänderung bei den
33 grad triebwerken des heavy boosters
bleibt es allerdings soll starship jetzt
statt 79 triebwerke bekommt auch darum
bei einem problem den stadtturm allein
ohne booster verlassen zu können und so
die crew zu retten denn notfall
triebwerke wie bei apollo oder der
kosaken wird es nicht mehr geben können
starship ist dafür zu schwer beim neuen
triebwerken kann dann sogar 1 ausfallen
und starship wäre immer noch zu einem
notstand in der lage zusammenkommen
booster und star jim damit auf 42
raptoren was ein wenig an per anhalter
durch die galaxis von douglas adams
erinnert da wird die frage nach dem
leben dem universum und dem ganzen rest
auch mit 42 beantwortet die triebwerke
sollen uns mit flüssigem methan
angetrieben werden und sauerstoff das in
solarbetriebenen fabriken aus co2 und
wasser hergestellt werden soll also das
methan ansonsten hat spacex mit dem mast
algorithmus mal wieder alles auf die
spitze getrieben und diese infos sind
ziemlich spektakulär und ziemlich mind
blowing schon bald sollen ein starship
und ein booster pro monat gebaut werden
später dann alle drei tage ein starship
booster werden weniger benötigt da sie
bei einem staat immer nach sechs minuten
wieder zurück sind mit einer solchen
menge an raumschiffen sollen dann
absolut neue dimensionen des transports
ins all erreicht werden mit einem
starship das dreimal in der woche
startet können in einem jahr so viel
tonnen material ins all gebracht werden
wie die menschheit bisher insgesamt ins
all transportiert dann pro flug 100 bis
150 tausend tonnen später sind dann drei
flüge pro tag geplant damit wäre dann
die siebenfache menge möglich und b10
starship wären es 70 mal soviel eine
million tonnen pro jahr für das ziel maß
wären es immerhin noch 100 bis 150
tausend tonnen pro jahr somit wären die
eine million tonnen für eine autarke
statt auf dem mars mit starship machbar
denn das betonte musk nochmal zu beginn
der präsentation dafür ist starship
gemacht um den menschen zur multi
planetaren spezies werden zu lassen und
weiter fort zugestehen auch wenn ein
asteroideneinschlag einzubringen kann
oder der klimawandel das leben auf der
erde unmöglich machen würde doch kann
man im zeitplan bleiben und wird es da
stimmt tatsächlich schon bald starten
sicher scheint dass keineswegs zu sein
denn die genehmigung der fr ob die
tatsächlich im märz schon vorliegt das
scheint mehr als fraglich es erinnert
ein wenig an die tester fabrik in
grünheide denn in texas droht ein
aufwendigeres umwelt prüfverfahren was
womöglich noch von der fdp verlangt wird
dann allerdings so mast gibt es
ausweichmöglichkeiten
denn auch in cape kennedy an der
startrampe 39a soll ein staat und faktor
gebaut werden und auch eine der beiden
ölplattformen die mast zum bau von
offshore start und landeplätze gekauft
hatte wird voraussichtlich noch dieses
jahr fertig und mit einem offshore
startplatz wäre er auf der sicheren
seite denn der könnte im zweifelsfall
erstmal in internationalen gewässern
operiert was die verfahren
voraussichtlich deutlich vereinfachen
würde es wird also spannend suche nach
außerirdischen mit space extrakte zum
der mond europa anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleibt